bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue sur
ce nouveau podcast dédié à la conservation des
espèces alors pour être tout à fait honnête avec
vous j'avais en fait prévu de vous le faire en
live sur la chaîne twitch chaîne twitch que j'ai
déjà commencé à paramétrer d'ailleurs mais qui
malheureusement n'est pas active pour le moment
car il se trouve que nous avons quelques soucis
d'ordi en ce moment et du coup les conférences
que julien avait prévu ainsi que les live que
je voulais vous faire sur la conservation des
espèces tout ça c'est un peu passé à la trappe
donc au lieu de les remettre à plus tard nous
avons décidé de vous les donner comme vidéos
youtube tout simplement sur la forme de podcasts
ou de cours dans le cas de julien en attendant
voilà ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y aura rien d'autre
de prévu après sur la chaîne, juste dire que
pour l'instant le programme que vous étiez censés
avoir en live, vous l'avez en podcast, ce qui
ma foi n'est pas si mal quand même. Bien évidemment
dès que nous suscitons redit son règle et vous
en serez informés via facebook twitter ou
instagram ou directement sur youtube. On vous
donnera tous les détails à présent concernant le
sujet du jour nous allons parler aujourd'hui de
législation mais alors attention pas de n'importe
quelle législation de nouvelles législations
concernant la conservation des espèces évidemment
et puis particulièrement le bien-être animal alors
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à une nouvelle loi
qui est sortie au royaume uni en juillet 2020
dunk de cette année une nouvelle loi qui déclare
les animaux s'en tient alors attention pas touche
mais on va s'intéresser à ça tout de suite
donc voilà le texte de loi en question et
avant qu'on commence sur ce texte de loi juste une
petite parenthèse rapidement sur la législation
française et sur ce qui se passe dans le monde en
règle générale les animaux de compagnie d'élevage
ou ceux qui se trouvent dans la nature sont
généralement considérés comme des choses comme
des meubles comme des possessions donc c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez posséder que
vous avez plus avez un animal de compagnie par
exemple vous possédez une vache ou un chat ou un
chien ou n'importe quoi et en l'occurrence c'est
considérer donc comme un objet il ya bien quelques
législation de par le monde qui considèrent les
animaux un peu différemment on en parlera tout à
l'heure mais ce n'était pas le cas du royaume uni
et c'est donc la première loi du royaume uni qui
contient le mot sans tiens en parlant d'un animal
et c'est pour ça que cette les filiations est très
importante pour le royaume uni et je m'étonne un
petit peu qu'elle n'ait pas fait plus de bruit
parce que c'est quand même un grand pas en avant
vers un futur qui me paraît un peu plus acceptable
pour l'ensemble des animaux de compagnie et des
animaux d'élevage ou autres animaux delà de la
planète en règle générale on va voir ça tout de
suite et on va voir aussi les conséquences que
cela peut avoir alors peut-être pas tout de suite
mais si jamais on poursuit dans cette fois il
peut y avoir pas mal de conséquences pour pour
la société et la manière dont nous considérons
les animaux au quotidien alors cette nouvelle loi
qu'est ce qu'il dit alors c'est ça s'appelle les
animaux warfare 7e acte toit ni toiture c'est
la création animaux sentjens comique et donc à
un comité sur la sentience animal qui va vérifier
que toutes les lois qui sortent une nouvelle loi
qui passe donc par les chambres pour être validés
pour pour entrer dans la vie publique au royaume
uni toutes ces lois respecte le bien-être animal
et donc son c'est ce comité un peu garant voilà du
bien-être animal au point de vue législatif alors
ce texte il est un petit peu curieux parce que ce
comité finalement on sait pas exactement comment
ça va se passer quelle chambre envoie les trucs au
comité pas énormément de on ne sait pas beaucoup
plus sur le fonctionnement du comité en lui même
on sait pas combien de membres à l'intérieur par
exemple on sait que les membres de comités ses
secrétaires d'état qui valait désigné mais on ne
sait pas sur quel critère je suis pas trop du coût
qui sera à l'intérieur de ce comité avant il ya
normalement tout le processus est notée dans la
loi pour être bien sûr que l'on fasse les choses
correctement c'est vrai que ça marche et là il
n'y a pas grand chose qui ait marqué là dedans
qu'on a un petit peu l'impression que cette loi
est uniquement là pour ajouter le nom sentience
le mot sentience dans la loi du royaume uni parce
que c'est un terme qui n'y étaient pas voilà donc
on a juste l'impression que cette loi c'est une
sorte de prête noms pour ajouter le mot sentience
à l'intérieur et c'est tout et ça c'est un peu le
cas d'ailleurs quand on y pense parce que je
ne sais pas si je m'imagine que vous le savez
il ya le brick city ya pas longtemps le royaume
uni donc est sortie de l'union européenne et il
se trouve que l'union européenne s'était déjà doté
lors du traité d'amsterdam de 97 il avait rajouté
donc une petite provision supplémentaire dans la
constitution qui parlait donc 2 wolf et donc de
bien être animal tout en respectant la législation
les administrations et les rites religieux ou
les habitudes des différents pays évidemment mais
voilà mais il y avait quand même ce terme animaux
a fait dans le texte de l'union européenne qui
est déjà quelque chose d'important et surtout
il y avait marqué qu'il désirait assurer une
protection et le respect pour le bien-être
animal en tant que être senti en voilà et ça ça
c'était très important et du fait du de la sortie
du royaume uni de l'union européenne à cause du
bric cité par ce terme animaux sans tian du moins
est ressenti en tant que quand on parle d'animaux
et ben n'était plus dans la loi de coûts j'utilise
était plus couverts par le texte de l'union
européenne et donc il était important pour eux
de rajouter ce terme dans leurs lois vu comment
les mentalités ont évolué depuis évidemment et
c'est pour ça que ce nouveau texte a été édictée
donc en 2022 pour en revenir aux textes de loi
vous noterez en dessous dans le petit paragraphe 5
interprétation animal dans ce texte veut dire tout
vertébrés autres qu'homo sapiens donc que l'humain
tout mollusques céphalopodes et tout crustacés des
capotes donc les mollusques céphalopodes les
poulpes les pilotes comme ça et les crustacés
des capotes bas les crabes les homards alors
pourquoi ces animaux là uniquement et pourquoi
pas les autres certes on peut se demander pourquoi
est-ce qu'un crabe serait plus s'en tient qu'une
abeille ce que bon la bei quand même sa vie en
groupe il ya quand même une certaine certaine
cohésion une mx 2 groupes ils ont même un langage
par exemple alors que le crabe ouais vous n'allez
quand même pas si sûr donc on peut se poser on
est en droit de se poser des questions c'est
sûr mais il ya une réponse toute simple à ça
et dans cette réponse il ya le mot souffrance
alors quel est le problème avec la souffrance on
commence à s'inquiéter du bien-être animal et de
la sentience animal lorsqu'on lorsqu'on sait quoi
utiliser ces animaux soit pour les manger donc et
une mise à mort et puis après on va les utiliser
pour autre chose soit lorsqu'on leur fait subir
des choses quand même assez désagréable comme par
exemple pour les homards pour les crabes en effet
bouillir vivant du coup on est un peu en droit
de s'inquiéter et de savoir si effectivement les
mettre dans de l'eau froide puis après augmenter
petit à petit la température pour que les pattes
se casse pas alors ce que lors de la cuisson
tout ça c'est la raison pour laquelle on les
met d'abord dans de l'eau froide et qu'on fait
ensuite bouillir petit à petit lorsque le trabet
encore dans l'eau froide dans la casserole et
qu'on la mène ensuite à ébullition ça évite que
les pâtes les appendices ne se détache du corps
et donc ça permet une meilleure présentation
dans l'assiette voilà vous me direz de toute
façon les faire bouillir directement juste les
plonger directement dans l'eau bouillante ça
doit certainement pas être beaucoup mieux donc
en l'occurrence on est en droit de s'interroger
sur la sentience de ces animaux est ce que ce
qu'on leur fait subir est ce qu'on ne ferait
pas subir à des êtres sentiment tout à fait
par hasard que là ce serait quand même un petit
peu plus embêtant alors là vous allez me dire oui
mais depuis tout à l'heure tu me parles de santé
oms animal est d'être champion sauf que je suis
toujours pas ce que ça veut dire d'accord donc
en tête commencer par ça une petite définition
de la sentience et pour définir la sentience il
va falloir d'abord définir la conscience parce que
les deux sont liés à l'or la conscience c'est quoi
la conscience c'est la capacité de nous rapporter
subjectivement nos propres états mentaux donc
en quelque sorte c'est cette conscience de soi
qu'on peut avoir cette capacité de réflexion de
créativité cette sorte de sagesse si on veut cette
connaissance qu'on peut utiliser ses expériences
passées qu'on a accumulées et c'est donc tout
ça c'est la conscience alors la conscience
vous avez l'impression que cette définition
est un peu décousu et c'est normal parce que la
conscience est extrêmement difficile à définir et
a certainement autant de définitions de conscience
qu'il a de gens qui ont essayé de la définir parce
que la conscience et parce qu'on essaie de définir
ce concept de conscience on essaie de le définir
avec notre propre conscience c'est à dire qu'on
est notre conscience pour définir le concept
de conscience vous voyez où je veux en venir là
c'est pas facile du coup c'est on utilise l'outil
en question pour essayer de définir cet outil
dont comprenez cette définition comme ce cas
les uns c'est juste une définition très basique
de la conscience y en a des centaines d'autres
certainement une dans le tas qui est un peu mieux
mais bon j'ai choisi de vous donner celle qui est
la plus basique la plus facile à appréhender
et puis de toute façon c'est tout ce dont on
a besoin pour aujourd'hui on n'aura pas besoin
d'aller plus loin on va pas à partir d'un des
condamnés dans des considérations philosophiques
on va rester assez basique mais une fois qu'on a
cette définition de la conscience par contre
on peut essayer de définir la sentience parce
que la sentir ce qu'est ce que c'est en quelque
sorte c'est là une sorte de conscience mais une
conscience niveau beaucoup plus bas donc ça va
être la capacité de ressentir des émotions la
capacité d'avoir des expériences vécues comme du
plaisir de la douleur de la peur mais ça va pas
être une certaine conscience de soi ça va pas être
une capacité de réflexion ou de créativité par
exemple on va rester sur un niveau très basique de
conscience donc la sentience prenez le comme une
sorte de conscience mais de conscience basique
voilà alors attention il n'y a pas qu'un seul
niveau de 106 ans non plus pour avoir des niveaux
de sentiers ans très basique et peut-être la
capacité uniquement de ressentir de trois émotions
d'avoir quelques expériences n'est pas forcément
de pouvoir agir sur pouvoir agir véritablement
sur ses expériences et d'en tirer des leçons en
quelque sorte et puis vous allez avoir des niveaux
de sentiers ans qui sont très très proches de ce
qu'on appelle la conscience humaine qu'on va
retrouver notamment chez les grands singes
qu'on va retrouver chez les oiseaux vous n'avez
les perroquets vous avez les corvidés vous avez
tout ce genre d'animaux qui sont capables d'avoir
une une sorte de sentier ans qui est très proche
de la nôtre tellement proches que des fois on
pourrait s'y tromper et qu'on pourrait peut-être
appeler ça une conscience d'ailleurs voilà tout
dépend de comment vous la définissez et c'est pour
ça que 700 science c'est quelque chose de capital
quand on a parlé de bien-être animal parce que la
sentience si c'est quelque chose c'est un concept
qui finalement nous fait prendre conscience à nous
en tant qu'humain que les animaux sont peut-être
pas humains mais ils ont la capacité d'exprimer
des émotions de ressentir des émotions et surtout
la capacité de ressentir la souffrance et c'est là
dessus qu'on va se baser pour savoir si l'animal
et s'en tient aux noms cette capacité à ressentir
la souffrance c'est d'ailleurs cette grosse
question qu'on se pose c'est pour ça que dans
cette loi il ya tout et crustacés des capotes
c'est parce qu'on se dit que possiblement si le
crabe y laissant tian quand vous le mettez dans
l'eau bouillante j'ai jamais été ébouillanté moi
même mais j'imagine que c'est pas tip top donc
on est en droit de se poser la question est ce
qu'on n'est pas en train dé bouillante est un être
qui est capable de ressentir de la douleur comme
nous qui est capable d'avoir des émotions comme
nous est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de faire une
sorte de meurtre a signé voilà un an et c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est important comme
question on est en droit de se poser la question
et c'est pareil pour les mollusques céphalopodes
les poules les pieuvres tous ces animaux qu'on
sait particulièrement intelligent d'ailleurs il
ya plein d'expérience qui ont été faites sur le
sujet qui sont capables de résoudre des problèmes
des labyrinthes plein de trucs plein de choses
c'est assez incroyable bas est ce que on n'est pas
en train de priver de leur liberté dans ce cas là
des animaux qui finalement une forme de conscience
et c est qu on ne devrait pas soit les garder en
captivité soit les manger tout simplement parce
que quand on mange de la salade de poulpe bas
est-ce qu'on serait pas en train de manger un
animal se maintient c'est peut-être là c'est une
question c'est une question qu'on peut se poser
et dans toute cette question de la sentience
est relié d'une certaine manière à la douleur
alors on a défini chez des animaux on a essayé
de déterminer s'il était capable de ressentir
la douleur ou non donc il ya plein d'expérience
qui ont été faites sur le sujet 1 il ya plein de
modes opératoires différents en fonction du type
de stimulus que vous utilisez mais attention ces
expériences là sont évidemment fait dans les
conditions très éthique il n'est pas question
de couper une patte un animal et de regarder s'il
a mal hein c'est pas ça le but quand vous essayez
de savoir si un animal ressent la douleur en fait
ce que vous faites mettons que vous voulez savoir
s'il réagit à des stimulus de chaleur vous allez
prendre une lumière infrarouge vous allez lui lui
miner la pâte avec cette lumière infrarouge et
vous le laisser choisir l'ours qui considérera
que ça commence quand même un peu à chauffer trop
il va retirer sa patte de lui-même dans ces cas
là vous n'allez pas lui le forcer à laisser sa
patte à l'endroit où la lumière si ça commence
à trop chauffer vous allez calculer le temps qu'il
met à retirer sa patte qui va vous donner du coup
la sensibilité de cet animal à ce stimulus
précis donc en l'occurrence la chaleur mais
en réalité c'est pas la douleur que vous testez
dans ces cas là c'est autre chose c'est juste
la présence des récepteurs sensoriels qui sont
liées à la captation de chaleur en l'occurrence
donc ces récepteurs sensoriels qui sont liées
à la douleur c'est ce qu'on appelle les no 6 70
à l'anoci c'était un peu partout sur votre corps
c'est ce que vous permet d'avoir le geste réflexe
de retirer votre main des plaques chauffantes par
exemple quand vous êtes tout petit puis essayer de
poser la main dessus et que vous brûlez voilà
ça certain que ça brûle ça c'est les ponots 6
septembre qui envoie le message jusqu'au thalamus
dans le cerveau qui lie attention ça crame tu es
en train de s'abîmer la pole à retiers retard
28 dont vous avez le geste réflexe de retirer
à la main et puis après peut-être vous allez
vous mettre à pleurer si si ça faisait vraiment
très très mal parce que bon quand même c'est une
expérience un peu traumatisante pour un enfant ne
va pas se le cacher et c'est justement là tout
le problème de la douleur c'est que on est tout
à fait capable de comprendre comment la douleur
fonctionne chez l'humain mais on n'est pas capable
de comprendre exactement si ça fonctionne de la
même manière chez les animaux je vous explique
chez les mains la douleur en réalité trois
composantes évidemment la composante physique
les no 6 septembre qui va vous donner tous les
gestes réflexes associé à la douleur donc retiré
la main si vous êtes sur les plaques chauffantes
par exemple ça c'est le geste réflexe qui associé
à la douleur mais il n'ya pas que ça il ya deux
autres composantes en réalité il ya une composante
affective et il ya une composante cognitives à la
douleur il y a trois composantes au total donc la
composante sensorielle on l'a vu c'est les no 6
septembre la composante affective en fait c'est
les émotions que vous allez avoir vis-à-vis de
cette douleur est ce que ça va être pénible est
ce que vous allez avoir peur est ce que ça va être
quelque chose qui fait quand même vachement mal
et que ça va être douloureux pendant plusieurs
jours et que bon vous allez vous sentir mal à
cause de ça et puis vous avez toute la composante
cognitive derrière tous les processus mentaux
l'anticipation l'interprétation de la douleur
votre adaptation du comportement etc tout ça
c'est ces trois composantes sont essentielles
à la douleur et chez l'humain c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui fait que vous pouvez avoir de la douleur
semble en fait avoir de composante essentielle
certaines fois c'est par exemple ce qui se passe
lorsque vous avez la douleur des membres fantômes
c'est à dire que met-on vous avez été amputée des
fois il vous arrivera quand même de ressentir de
la douleur dans ce membre même s'il n'est plus
présent et donc dans ces cas là c'est les deux
autres composantes qui vont jouer un rôle derrière
il vous aurait pu la composante sensorielles ou
alors exactement de la même manière donc voilà
c'est c'est un peu le problème avec la douleur
c'est que vous avez trois composantes et que
chez les animaux nous ne sommes capables de
tester qu'une seule de ses composantes qui est la
composante sensorielle et donc celle qui est la
présence ou l'absence de nos 6 septembre c'est le
seul truc qu'on est capable de tester et non plus
du coup tester la sensibilité des no 6 septembre à
un stimulus donnait donc en l'occurrence à chaleur
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure mais vous n'allez
pas pouvoir tester les deux autres composantes à
moins que ce soit vraiment chez des animaux qu'ils
soient très proches de nous comme des mammifères
par exemple à la rigueur et encore je ne suis
pas sûr que vous arrivez à tester ça chez une
chaise une souris mais chez un grand singe par
exemple vous allez pouvoir tester la composante
affective peut-être de la douleur ou cognitif
donc ça ça va être ça va être des choses qui
vont être possible chez des espèces très proche
de nous j'ai des espèces un peu plus éloignés ça
va être plus compliqué vous pourrez certainement
tester la présence de nos 6 septembre chez une
limace mais vous pourrez pas testé la composante
cognitive et la composante affective ça va pas
être possible et vous pouvez pas savoir si ali
massa des émotions j'y arriverai pas vraiment
à savoir si elle a réfléchi à cette histoire
de douleur ou pas ça en l'état où on en est
actuellement des connaissances ça ne va pas être
possible le bref aussi imparfaite que soit cette
méthode pour tester la sentience animal le fait
d'utiliser la douleur je dirais que c'est un peu
la seule carte convenait parce que du coup les
émotions ça marche pareil que chez une certaine
tranche d'animaux parce que on pourrait se dire
la sentience c'est le fait d'avoir des émotions
mais c'est pareil c'est pas tes stable chez
beaucoup d'animaux ça on n'arrivera pas à le
tester donc ça va pas être possible ou alors on
pourrait réussir peut-être basse et la capacité
à communiquer dans ces cas là qui permet de
savoir si l'animal et s'en tient au peuple après
tout si communique c'est qu'il ya une certaine
conscience de ce qui se passe autour de lui mais
si on considère à la communication comme moyen
de déterminer la sentience il va falloir prendre
aussi en compte les arbres les plantes parce que
les plantes sont capables de communiquer entre
elles via des messagers chimiques par exemple
pour s'avertir de la proche d'insectes ravageurs
ou de danger que ce soit des maladies autres
trucs les arbres certains arbres sont capables
s'avertir les uns les autres vient messagers
chimiques et c'est une forme de communication
comme une autre c'est une forme de communication
via messagers chimiques après tout nous aussi on
communique chimiquement on a des phéromones c'est
une forme de communication c'est pareil et c'est
en ça que ça va pas être possible d'utiliser la
communication pour déterminer si l'animal est
conscient pas parce que sinon ça veut dire qu'on
doit vraiment inclus à là dedans une grosse partie
du règne végétal avec aussi enfin bref du coup
tout dépend où vous mettez la limite mais c'est
pour ça qu'on utilise ses expériences sur la
douleur parce que c'est plus ou moins la seule
chose qu'on ait de disponible aujourd'hui pour
déterminer une sorte de sentiment chez l'animal
aussi imparfaite que cela soit voilà c'est les
seules expériences qu'on a vraiment sous la main
alors ces expériences évidemment on les a
faites sur des vertébrés sur des mammifères
des rats par exemple c'est l'animal de l'animal
test par excellence mais aussi sur des crabes
et c'est justement le sujet d'un article de
2013 cet article de 2013 a fait grand bruit
qui a été relayée par pas mal de plateformes pas
mal de l'association animal aussi et cet article
de 2013 avait déterminé que les crabes était
capable non seulement de ressentir la douleur
donc via les no 6 70 mais aussi de déterminer
si les crabes été capable de choisir entre deux
endroits un endroit qui avait un stimulus
pas très agréable et un endroit avec un
stimulus beaucoup plus agréable beaucoup plus
normal suite à leur expérience passée c'est
à dire que il les a émus donc dans deux boîtes
différentes il y avait des boîtes où il ressent
d un certain confort et il y avait des boîtes
ou au contraire tout allait bien et donc les
chercheurs avaient déterminé que les crabes
après être passés plusieurs fois par toutes
les boîtes à les choisir de même la boîte qui
finalement avait été la plus agréable pour eux
de par leur expérience donc ça signifiait que
les crabes avait une capacité d'une d'apprendre
de leurs expériences passées et ensuite d'agir
grâce à leur expérience passée et de choisir
grâce à cela donc il y avait non seulement une
capacité effectivement de ressentir l'inconfort
où la douleur via les no 6 septembre mais y avait
en plus une capacité de réflexion derrière pour
avoir un choix éclairé ne sorte sur le meilleur
endroit dans lequel tu pouvais évidemment c'est
suite à ces articles qu'on va trouver dans
cette loi notamment que un animal quand on
parle de sentiments son animal ça s'adresse aussi
aux crabes donc c'est à cause de cet article là
par contre il va juste falloir rappeler quand
même et modérer ses propos un petit peu par le
fait que en 2016 les mêmes auteurs ont publié une
contre étude qui finalement disait oui bon en fait
qu'on a publié en 2013 finalement ça marche pas
si bien que ça peut-être que les crabes sont pas
capables de réfléchir sur leur expérience donc
ils sont effectivement capable de ressentir la
douleur mais après niveau gain de connaissances
grâce à leurs expériences et réflexions à partir
de ses connaissances ya par contre on voit là ce
n'était pas convaincant du tout leurs résultats
donc faut juste mitigé un petit peu ses résultats
au niveau scientifique pour l'exemple pour les
crabes ça n'a pas été prouvé qu'ils sont capables
de réfléchir sur sur ça et puis comme je le disais
au début après tout si un crabe est capable de
réfléchir dans ces cas là on peut supposer que
des guêpes des abeilles des insectes sociaux en
règle générale c'est aussi tout à fait capables
d'avoir ce même type de comportement ce même type
de réflexion et ce serait dommage dans ces cas là
de ne pas inclure les insectes dans les lois
qui parle des animaux s'en tient si on inclut
les crabes j'aimerais aussi qu'on n'a plus les
hexapode au niveau scientifique d'ailleurs on a
effectivement prouvé que chez les insectes et chez
d'autres petits animaux il ya présence de nos six
secteurs c'est pas ils ressentent effectivement
la douleur physique donc comme nous ils ont cette
capacité sensorielle de ressentir la douleur
après on est incapable de savoir s'il ya des
émotions en plus cette su comme chez nous mais au
moins physiquement parlant il ya les récepteurs
ya les no 6 septembre pour la douleur donc pas
assez comme nous quand ils sont malins ils le
ressentent alors ses expériences sur la douleur
chez les animaux c'est pas les seuls trucs qu'on
peut ramener nos connaissances sur la sentience
animal au niveau scientifique et aussi d'autres
choses et en l'occurrence il ya nos connaissances
neurologiques sur l'humain et sur l'animal qu'on
peut aussi rajouter à ça c'est à dire qu'en gros
on a constaté notamment chez les mammifères que
ils avaient les mêmes structures dans le cerveau
que nous et que du coup vu qu'il y avait la même
substrat il y avait possiblement les mêmes
émotions qui pouvaient s'y développer oui si
vous avez une structure similaire ça veut dire
que vous pouvez possiblement l'utiliser pour la
même chose un peu là dessus que basés tous les
les interprétations qu'elles sont basées toutes
les interprétations en paléontologie d'ailleurs
on considère que une structure similaire va avoir
plus ou moins la même utilité comme ça qu'on peut
interpréter des tas de choses et en l'occurrence
pour la conscience c'est pareil on considère que
si vous avez un cerveau qui est plus ou moins fait
de la même manière bas vous pouvez faire plus
ou moins les mêmes trucs voilà et donc vu qu'on
a les zones du cerveau similaire baham on se dit
que il possiblement les émotions qui viennent de
ces zones du cerveau qui conserve nir de ces
zones là sont possiblement présente alors on
en a pas la preuve mais vu qu'on a la structure
on se dit que voilà il ya une forte probabilité
que ça existe et c'est là-dessus qui est basée
la déclaration cambridge de 2012 qui dit que
l'absence de néocortex ne semble pas empêcher
un organisme d'éprouver des états affectifs des
données convergentes indique que les animaux non
humains possèdent des substrats neuro anatomique
neurochimique et neurophysiologiques des étapes
conscient ainsi que la capacité de se livrer à
des comportements attentionnel par conséquent
la force des preuves nous amène à conclure
que les humains ne sont pas seuls à posséder
les substrats neurologiques de la conscience
des animaux non humains notamment l'ensemble des
mammifères et des oiseaux ainsi que de nombreuses
autres espèces telles que les pieuvres possède
également ces substrats neurologiques nous mais
on repart encore sur les vertébrés et sur les
céphalopodes en l'occurrence les pieuvres la
comédie alors cette sas avait été publié en 2002
évidemment l'article de 2013 sur les crabes était
pas encore sorti donc c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
pas inclus là dedans mais faut bien voir que bon
après cet article de 2013 beaucoup de gens ont
commencé à intégrer les crustacés décapodes à
l'heure leur quota d'animaux sentir en quelque
sorte les îles les on partirait en 2016 notre
problème est là mais ça vient ça vient de là
donc ça le fait d'avoir les mêmes structures
c'est aussi une autre pierre a amené à l'édifice
de la sentience animal donc non seulement ils
ressentent la douleur comme nommé ils ont aussi
les structures neurologique et c'est donc suite à
toutes ces expériences déclarations de 2012 offre
avec toutes ses connaissances qu'on a commencé à
accumuler que petit à petit la législation de
par le monde a commencé à changer ou du moins
inclure le mot sentiers en parlant d'animaux
dans leurs lois et ça se voit pas mal avec
la déclaration toulon de 2019 ou l'a carrément
ce sont des juristes de l'université de toulon
qui répondent cette fois ci à la déclaration
de cambridge de 2012 en disant que vu que ces
animaux sont considérés conscient il va falloir
leur accorder un statut juridique cette fois là
qu'il soit adapté et donc dans cette déclaration
de toulon vous pouvez trouver notamment nous
déclarons que les animaux doivent être considéré
de manière universelle comme des personnes et non
des choses donc c'est là où je voulais en venir
c'est que suite à toutes ces découvertes sur la
nociception chez les animaux on commence cette
fois ci rentrait dans le domaine juridique et
donc on en arrive à ces déclarations de 2019 à
toulon alors là pour l'instant c'est pas rentrer
dans les lois suisses une déclaration ça n'a rien
à voir avec la loi française pour l'instant mais
en quelques sorte c'est un premier pas peut-être
pour un jour considéré ou pour un jour changer
le statut de l'animal vis-à-vis de la de la loi
française et qu'ils soient considérés comme autre
chose puisque dans cette déclaration toulon du
coup ils veulent considérer à l'animal non plus
comme une chose mais comme une personne pour se
dire qu'on on va non plus le considérer comme un
meuble une possession on va le ramener au rang
de ce qu'ils appellent un sujet de droit c'est
à dire que c'est une personne comme vous et moi
qui va quoi avoir des droits comme une personne
mon souci avec tout ça c'est que ont pour
l'instant cette histoire de santé oms animal
c'est très bien de déclarer que les animaux sont
sentis en qu'effectivement faut les traiter avec
respect avec une certaine éthique faut pas faire
n'importe quoi que tu as beau posséder un animal
n'est pas censé lui faire du mal voilà il ya pas
mal de choses qu'on peut essayer de développer
à partir de ça mais comment c'est à dire que les
animaux sont des personnes et donc des sujets de
droit aux yeux de la loi ça veut dire quoi rêver
ça veut dire qu'ils font partie de notre société
à nous or pour vivre en société vous le savez
vous comme moi il y a chacun chaque individu
dans cette société a des droits mais aussi des
devoirs est ce qu'il est possible de demander
un animal d'avoir à la fois des droits et des
devoirs ça va être compliqué et ce que du coup
on peut leur accorder le même statut juridique
l humain je sais pas peut-être qu'on pourrait
trouver un statut entre les deux est ce que ce
serait peut-être possible voilà il faut aussi
comprendre que si jamais on élève l'animal au
rang de personnes il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
pu être possible dans notre société qui est par
exemple la possession d'un animal tout simplement
vous avez un animal de compagnie bah non non vous
n'avez pas d'animal de compagnie vous ne possédez
plus si c'est une personne vous possédez pas la
personne qui quand ça s'appelle de l' esclavage
c'est pas vous c'est pas possible vous pouvez pas
par exemple les élever pour ensuite les envoyer à
l'abattoir saad ça va pas être possible c'est
dans ce cas là c'est un meurtre si vous tuez
une autre personne et c'est ça le problème
c'est que du coup si vous les élever au même
rang que l'humain dans la loi vous allez avoir
toutes ses conséquences qui vont en découler
est-ce que vous pouvez amener votre chat chez
le véto pour le stériliser 6 vous considérez
que c'est une personne bah non clairement ça va
pas être possible on peut pas lui faire faire
une opération comme ça contre son gré voilà donc
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'il faut prendre en
compte avant de mettre ce genre de trucs dans
les lois notre société qu'on le veuille ou non
est basé sur des animaux alors que seuls les
animaux de compagnie que ce soit les animaux
qu'on utilise pour le travail il ya encore
pas mal d'endroits dans le monde on utilise
des chevaux ou des boeufs pour pour faire les
champs que soient les animaux qu'on utilise pour
l'élevage pour ensuite les abattre que ce soit
les animaux qu'on va juste un peu parasite est
en quelque sorte comme les abeilles du coup les
élèves on les protège mais on récupère alors leur
production voilà il ya beaucoup de choses comme
ça qui si jamais on met que c'est des personnes
dans la loi ça va plus être possible et c'est pour
ça que du coup ce pas n'a pas encore été franchie
et si jamais il est franchie un jour faudra le
faire avec beaucoup d'intelligence et beaucoup
de réflexion avant de faire ça et peut-être faudra
faudra attendre d'avoir une solution de rechange
avant de vouloir faire quelque chose comme ça
parce que ça va ça va être très compliqué sinon
c'est foncièrement impossible pour l'instant de ne
pas vivre avec les animaux faut voir aussi que si
jamais vous commencez à considérer les animaux
comme des personnes vous n'aurez plus non plus
le droit d'aller polluer les espaces naturels qui
sont les lieux de vie d'autres espèces d'animaux
qui sont du coup des personnes parce que vous
allez leur nuire dans ces cas là donc toutes
les exploitations tous les choses où on va couper
du bois où on va extraire des minerais où on va
empiéter du coup sur leur territoire bas c'est
pareil ça va plus être possible on va considérer
ces animaux comme des communautés peut-être
par email mais des communautés animales pour
locaux et dans ces communautés animales et bah si
jamais vous commencez à endommager leurs lieux de
vie leurs habitations ce sera certainement des
activités qui seront à la loi donc l'utilisation
des ressources naturelles sera beaucoup plus
compliqué dans ces cas là donc c'est pour ça
que voilà le maître que les animaux sont sentir
dans une loi c'est très bien parce que ça dénote
d'une évolution des mentalités et ça montre que
effectivement on considère plus juste l'animal
comme une possession que l'on considère que
maintenant il est quand même capable d'avoir
des émotions qui est capable de réagir de manière
d'avoir voilà d'avoir une sorte de sang science
et ça c'est bien de le considérer maintenant il
faut faire attention aussi à ne pas aller trop
loin sinon ça à vitre être invivable pour nous
voilà donc il ya tout un panel de conséquence
à toutes ces actions à tout c'est toutes ces lois
ici vous pouvez pas non plus posséder des animaux
vous pouvez pas non plus avoir de parc zoologique
par exemple parce que c'est des endroits où on
restreint la liberté de ces animaux mais en cage
en quelque sorte même si c'est plus vraiment des
cages de nouveau il faut pas se leurrer à part
quelques parcs qui font qu'ils sont restés dans
le dix neuvième siècle le reste a quand même pas
mal évolué surtout en europe où là on a vraiment
des parcs de zoologique où les animaux sont
soignés un régime cinq étoiles vraiment mais
du coup si on commence à considérer les animaux
comme des personnes les mettre dans des parcs ça
vous donner un petit air d'exposition universelle
de 1900 avec les indigènes qui ont ramené à paris
pour pour les montrer comme des animaux doha
dans ces cas là voilà tout ça c'est plein de
choses auxquelles il va falloir réfléchir avant
de continuer dans cette voie là et j'espère
qu'on trouvera le moyen d'améliorer le bien-être
animal la manière dont les animaux sont traités
en captivité est dans la nature d'ailleurs la
manière dont on traite les environnements autour
de nous aussi j'espère qu'on trouvera un moyen
d'améliorer tout ça sans pour autant partir dans
l'excès inverse j'aimerais pour une fois on trouve
un juste milieu qu'on arrive à se mettre d'accord
sur quelque chose qui soit à la fois bon pour les
animaux est bon pour l'humain alors avant de vous
quitter j'aimerais vous proposer une dernière
question pour une salle comme une espèce de
comme une sorte de petite réflexion à prendre avec
vous peut-être est-ce que vous pensez que celle
les animaux on considère sans tian ont le droit à
notre respect et à être traités de manière éthique
voilà une question très très ouverte ça dépend
encore une fois comment il est terminée les
termes respect éthique etc mais je trouve la
question intéressante parce qu'après tout pour
l'instant on parle juste senti ans à nîmes a
laissé les seuls animaux qu'on inclut dans nos
lois ce qu'on considère comme sentir les autres
par contre ils n'ont pas voix au chapitre est ce
que pour vous c'est normal est ce que non est-ce
que ba peut-être que sinon on en fait trop ou
pas assez voilà donc posez-moi vos réflexions
ensuite dans les commentaires c'est à vous de
voirs c'est un sujet qui est très ouvert très
discuté très difficile à appréhender j'espère
que je l'ai amené de la manière la plus claire et
la plus scientifique possible donc c'est un sujet
qui est très controversé qui est en plein dans
l'actualité donc évidemment ça discute beaucoup
autour mais je trouvais justement que cette cette
nouvelle loi était l'occasion d'en parler un petit
peu de soulever ces questions et voir avec vous
ce que vous en pensez j'aurais préféré le faire
en live pour avoir vos réactions directement
mais on se contentera des commentaires donc
n'hésitez pas et moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures avec des plumes